recapping our top story president Trump
is rolling out a trillion and a half
dollar to rebuild u.s. infrastructure
one of the most ambitious construction
projects in the u.s. is running into
some bureaucratic roadblocks it involves
a crucial transportation route and
questions about whether President Trump
and Congress will come up with the money
to pay for it
here's correspondent Douglas Kennedy so
you had 13 million gallons of water
inside these tunnels after Hurricane
sandy yeah the water got up to about
eight foot high in the tubes
Tyrone Gordon is an engineer for Amtrak
and in charge of overseeing the North
River tubes under the Hudson River the
nation's busiest transit route
connecting New York City to the southern
half of the East Coast's over the past
five years you've had seven major
electrical outages in these tunnels yes
that what that does every reduces the
amount of trains we can run at a certain
time
this is a piece of electrical cable from
inside this tunnel as you can see it is
completely corroded from saltwater
exposure and concrete inside the tunnel
built in 1910 is also crumbling John
Porcari heads the Gateway project a plan
among other things to build a new
transit tunnel from New Jersey to New
York so it's really impossible to repair
these tunnels because it would
essentially transit all over the
East Coast that that's right Douglas the
existing hundred and seven year old
tunnel is a single point of failure for
ten percent of America's gross domestic
product we need to build the new tunnel
then repair the old ones the Obama
administration called gateway the most
important infrastructure project in the
country and pledged to fund half of the
30 billion dollar price tag in September
President Trump agreed but in December
the president seemed to change his mind
after a letter from his transportation
administration called the deal quote
non-existent so you've already started
construction on Gateway and the Trump
administration is now threatening to
pull funding what are you gonna do well
like any project of national
significance it's a federal local
partnership I'm confident over the long
term that we will have our federal
partner at the table in the end he says
the tunnel simply cannot be built
without federal help under Manhattan
Douglas Kennedy Fox News